okay so we're going to get started this
panel is about the the role of civil
society which is a concept that we'll be
diving into a little bit we'd like to
talk about inclusion beyond buzz words
what does inclusion really mean what
does it entail
how does it work right like in in real
life we will be talking about how civil
society organizations can help steer a
eye towards sustainable development
goals and I have with me four panelists
that I chose because I have a lot of
admiration for the work of all four of
them I'm their biggest fan so I'm happy
to introduce I'll go in order
Milind tambay yes we need we're
switching the slides okay next slide the
title slide oh this one okay no no the
title won the titles like the four
speaker slide we're gonna make it yes
that's the perfect one it's not showing
there okay okay I would like to
introduce my first guest millington Bay
who is coming from the University of
Southern California and I would like to
start by explaining why I'm so happy to
have milind with us today I found when I
was doing research and I discovered that
he decided to join the Faculty of
engineering with the Faculty of Social
Work I don't think I've ever seen that
anywhere else in any other university
setting in other cities and I thought
that's absolutely genius and I'm gonna
let him explain why he did that
but that's what grasped my
tenshun most of his research is focused
on developing more AI for good and they
work he works with citizens addressing
present social issues he is the
co-founder and co-director of the Center
for AI in society in Los Angeles
Milind has been awarded two very
prestigious prizes this year and very
well-deserved the John McCarthy award
again I think that was pretty much award
because of the work on AI for good and
it's tremely well deserved he also
received the triple a Robert angle more
award which is quite the honor and just
published a book AI and social work and
he will be talking about the various
projects so I will introduce each
speaker and and then we can go ahead
with the presentations Mike scorpan from
Pittsburgh is here with us Mike well I
found Michael when I was trying to find
interesting ways of engaging citizens
his research that I publications or
something I found his his text and he
does interactive theatre and so I'll let
him explain what he does but that's how
I found and the interest I got so
Michael is the direct executive director
of community forge is a community
organization in Pittsburgh and special
faculty at Carnegie Carnegie Mellon his
focus is working on in historically
marginalized communities and as I
mentioned uses art to engage with
citizens kathleen semi-new has come all
the way from Kenya to be with us today
so we're really happy to have her I met
Kathleen in Geneva in May last year I
was completely impressed by her work the
why Kathleen sparked my little happy
spot was that she it's really a
grassroots movement that developed its
own civil society organization and she
is now the head of data science at
Africa is talking and the co-founder an
organizer of Nairobi woman in machine
learning she's also part of deep
learning in dhaba and you'll have to
explain to me what in dhaba a story
steering committee her focus is on
computational perception and robotics
and NLP for african languages and last
but not the least
Dongwoo is an emerging future policy
leader he his work is absolutely
fascinating he's a research fellow at
the asia-pacific foundation of Canada he
has two masters in one in Chinese
studies and the other one in political
science he's blending his experience and
studies to focus on analyzing AI
policies in East Asia and their
implications for Canada and there is a
five-part report that is due on Chinese
Japanese South Korean AI policies and
again their implications for Canada so
please give a nice warm round of
applause to welcome our speakers
and I would like to invite milind to
give his presentation so everyone's
going to do a brief presentation of the
work that they're doing and then we're
gonna break into a panel discussion and
then we'll be saving a little time for
some questions at the end
there's ten minute for questions sound
okay yes wonderful okay thank you
million thank you for organizing this
workshop it's a wonderful workshop I've
enjoyed the whole day today thank you
for all the wonderful speakers and thank
you for this kind introduction
so I'm milling tombe so I come from this
Center for AI in society a collaboration
between our School of Engineering and
School of Social Work so the premise
here is that with the recent advances in
AI and multi-agent systems we have a
tremendous opportunity to use these
advances towards societal benefit and
I'll focus on three areas in our Center
we focused on public safety and security
conservation and public health what ties
these areas together is that viewing
these problems as multi-agent systems
there's a key research challenge that
cuts across these areas how to optimize
the use of limited intervention
resources when interacting with other
agents in these domains and we've used
computational game theory as a key tool
in trying to handle these problems with
respect to public safety and security
the challenge is that we have a large
number of targets to protect and limited
security resources how to schedule or
plan or allocate these resources taking
into account of watchful adversary we've
contributed a new model called
Stackelberg security games and developed
new algorithms that are in use by
security agencies such as the Federal
Air Marshal Service in assigning air
marshals to flights in the United States
and also internationally such as
patrolling in ports such as Singapore
with respect to conservation the
challenge is that we have large
conservation areas to protect but
limited number of Rangers a concrete
example is work that we've been doing
with Uganda wildlife Authority in Uganda
for the past several years you heard
from my former PhD student Faye Fang
about this this morning the here the
model that we've contributed is called
green security games the idea is that by
taking past poaching data into account
we can predict where poachers will set
snares and for the past several years
have been able to show that we can
remove a large number of snares and even
get poachers arrested and the models
being extended towards illegal fishing
and trying to prevent illegal logging a
third area is public health here we have
to inform a large number of people but
have limited messaging resources a
concrete example is work they've been
doing with homeless shelters in Los
Angeles but we are trying to inform
homeless youth about dangers of HIV with
rates of HIV amongst homeless youth are
ten times the rate of normal house
population we've shown that by
harnessing the social networks of these
youth our AI influence maximization
algorithms are far more effective in
spreading HIV information compared to
traditional approaches and we are now
extending these approaches towards other
public health challenges including
malnutrition tuberculosis and others in
all of these cases coming to the theme
of this panel interdisciplinary
partnerships with government and
non-governmental organizations are
crucial and to that end we've really
patrolled with the coast guard in their
boards in the Port of New York for
example or really patrolled with
conservation agencies such as Panthera
in forests in Malaysia our students
spend time in homeless shelters talking
to homeless shelter officials or looking
at primary health care centers in India
and visiting them and understanding our
tuberculosis treatment gets sent out so
this immersion is important in trying to
understand what kind of data to really
collect and what kinds of problems to
focus on based on the basis of which we
can then develop our predictive
algorithms our machine learning
algorithms this will allow us to
separate out high and low risk cases but
the next step of course is prescription
because we have limited intervention
resources where to apply them that's
where our planning our game theoretic
reasoning comes in but we are interested
in taking this one step further so in
all of our projects we are very keen on
taking this out into pilot tests in the
real world
and this is important not only because
we are interested in the social impact
but because it teaches us something
about what might be wrong in our models
and how we could improve them and in
some cases of course we are lucky and
find a partner who can take this to
scale one concrete example of taking
this to scale is work that we've been
doing that the smart partnership which
is a global partnership of conservation
agencies such as World Wildlife Fund
Wildlife Conservation Society and others
to take our software for predicting
poaching attacks and Patrol planning -
600 national parks around the globe so
this is work that's ongoing and we hope
that by 2019 this software will be
rolled out another example is work
they've been doing with homeless
shelters in LA so we've just completed a
study with 900 homeless youth about
spreading information about HIV and
trying to I send it towards substance
abuse prevention suicide prevention
another so when our mayor talks about
the humanitarian crisis we are facing in
Los Angeles with the homeless population
with over 60,000 people who sleep on our
streets we are really grateful that with
AI we can contribute to help citizens in
our city I'll make one final point when
we talk about AI for social good it is
important step out of the lab and into
the field this is important in order to
build the right kinds of
interdisciplinary partnerships to
understand right kinds of problems to
solve and understand what deficiencies
exist in our models so thank you and
that's the book that was mentioned ai
and social work if you buy copies of the
book then from the royalties I can take
my PhD students out to a nice dinner so
I hope you'll consider that thank you
thank you
and we're now going to welcome Mike
scorpan
thanks everybody and thanks to these
really awesome panelists I'm gonna be a
lot faster just kind of give people a
sense of what I'm actually doing I'm the
director of a community center that is
near where I grew up and it's in a
neighborhood that has sort of been left
behind in a lot of the development in
Pittsburgh and has a lot of amazing
assets and that I've always wanted to
give back to since it's really close to
where I grew up which was part of the
area of Pittsburgh that was very
severely impacted by the end of the
steel industry but then I also continued
some of my work in engineering at
Carnegie Mellon primary doing computing
ethics so this is just a couple photos
to sort of ground you and what I'm doing
in the community so that building is a
retired school that was abandoned and
had been vacant for five years in a
community that was really interested in
seeing that school not get knocked down
and not become a site of gentrification
a space where it would be like lofts or
something on inaccessible to the
community we found it when we were
thinking about putting an education
nonprofit in this community and then
found that the community was very very
passionate about this being saved as a
space and so we ended up buying it with
a loan that was a little bit of a
challenge thing to get but essentially
this ended up taking me way off my path
from applied machine learning that I was
doing in graduate school and into just
doing community development work and so
we their focus on equitable economic
development so we help local
entrepreneurs get access to social
capital and real capital as well as just
training and and readiness programs we
also do youth in Powerman twerk and what
we call neighborhood well-being work
which is often building the bridges and
breaking down the silos between
communities that exists that create the
marginalization or make it even further
and then so over in the university
setting I'm pushing for ethics and
computing and I design curriculum for
different professors to implement to add
ethics and a technical curriculum and so
where a lot of this gets married my sort
of ethics side that's technical and then
this community development side is
actually in my artistic practice so this
is some photo
from an immersive theater piece that I
wrote while I was in graduate school
called quantified self and the goal was
to create a space where technical
experts as well as members of the public
could have a meaningful way to talk and
actually debate or show different
perspectives on the ethics of technology
development in particular AI
and data ownership and so we actually
implemented about 10 real technologies
that you could share your data with live
and use as fake products and a company
that you were experiencing a night when
a whistle-blower showed up at a public
event and you kind of are at the heart
of a sort of corporate ethical dilemma
and get the chance to talk about it in
different spaces and this was actually
after multiple years of research of my
own of learning that stories and
scenarios are really great place for
multiple stakeholders to come together
and explore ethics because you're not
leaving this like higher ground of oh
you're the machine learning expert and
I'm just this person who feels weird
about it all and instead it creates a
symmetry where it's more about the felt
experiences and the social impacts that
are happening in the story and whether
they were ok and whether the right
decisions were made and what
consideration should be made so that
that's all thank you thank you no that's
ok
so we're going to welcome Kathleen my
name is Kathleen as has been mentioned
I'm a science at a company called Africa
stalking I'm not gonna dwell on my work
there because I don't think it's an
interesting stuff but Africa stalking is
a communication service provider with a
focused on with a focus on software
developers this just means that we build
api's and then software developers build
front-facing applications
our products are SMS ussd voice payments
and airtime so guys build all sorts of
things using these products outside of
that I also co-founded and co-organized
the Nairobi women in machine learning
and data science community I'm
passionate about democratizing machine
learning just because we've seen the
effects of all sorts of solutions being
taken from one contact and transplanted
to another without paying attention to
the effects or the different nuances
that come with different contexts so
just empowering people to with the
technical skill to be able to implement
their own machine learning solutions is
something that I feel very passionate
about
we started this community mainly because
there was no such space back home so out
of a need for just two for ourselves to
gain technical skill to find peers who
can aid our learning journeys and we do
this through monthly meetups we've done
monthly meetups for the past two years
through that we've learned what works
what does not work we've been playing
around with different models so outside
of monthly meetups we also have study
groups we have activities like
hackathons basically just stuff that is
going to help the women in our community
to number one gets the technical skill
number two like I mentioned get peers
who can aid their learning journeys and
then number three activities which they
can engage in to just practice the skill
think through problems and see how they
can implement solutions to fix that I am
also part of the organizing on the
steering committee for the deep learning
in dhaba which much like the
women in machine learning communities
just about democratizing machine
learning but it's just plugging into a
wider network and connecting with people
all across Africa so we have a an annual
conference which takes place yeah once a
year an annual conference and in
addition to that we have independently
organized in dhabas which are organized
by people who attend the main in dhaba
so like last year we had 13 in dhaba x's
and it's really just nice to see all of
this being able to be perpetuated by
looking forward to supporting about 20
to 25 in dhaba access in different
African countries next year and like
this year we had representation from 33
African countries at the in dhaba so
it's also just a it's it's nice to see
the community grow to be involving other
countries even as we you know going to
the age of AI and ml to look back and
see who is not here how can we get them
here and yeah that's it thank you thank
you and now I would like to welcome
dongle okay oh do you have any political
scientist in the room anyone with a
political science degree oh yeah thank
you fair - okay so I'm going to talk
about the role of civil society from the
perspective of a political scientist so
I've looked at a policies in East Asia
so China South Korea and Japan and in
doing that I came across this book all
called AI superpowers where dr. Kai
fully talks about how China will be a
leader in is or will be a leader in AI
because there's not a lot of regulations
that hinder our innovation and that
there's a lot of data and that's why and
he talks about that dichotomy between
innovation and regulation and so in and
that's a that's a narrative that we hear
a lot even here
Canada or in the United States that we
know we need to support innovation and
you know our innovation is shouldn't be
hindered by other external concerns and
such this is an extreme picture but bear
with me so I found a difficult from from
this book to be quite troubling because
in the Chinese system is very particular
in that the government there is a very
strong hierarchy between government and
private sector so the government is able
to shut down our operations when there
is a problem and that's how they earned
the public trust but in case of Canada
or other Western countries we do it
through the rule of law there is a
procedure in which we are we do things
and we make decisions and here the civil
society plays a very very important role
in by promoting promoting the opinions
the views of citizens which is really
diverse it's basically a free market of
opinions but that's getting promoted to
governments and and businesses and in
that our government gets legitimacy we
we think that the government is the
government of the people and this is not
so much the case in in East Asia so and
more so this is an issue as everyone is
thinking about coming up with AI policy
for each government in case of Korea
Japan and South Korea they have all come
up with very comprehensive AI strategy
which not only supports research and
development but they talk about how
they're gonna use AI for our national
security public safety all from a more
centralized manner and but then in
formulating those policies they
acknowledge that there is a need to to
address citizen concerns public concerns
but because the civil society is so much
weaker in China Korea and Japan that
knowledge is missing and in that context
for the the strength of civil society
that we have here in Canada and other
parts in the Western world it's really a
strength it's something that could
really add value to the techni to to AI
innovation that we have
people come to Montreal people come to
Canada because we have really excellent
researchers but also what I've heard
from from Koreans and the Japanese and
some of the other foreign ops observers
is that they also find a Canadian value
of a good governance and openness and
diversity as another attraction because
Canada wouldn't be able to compete with
a Fayette China or the United States in
terms of dollar amounts but they find
those values are to be appealing and in
US and I think that week we could
enhance the quality of our our of our a
I brand here in Canada by better
integrating civil society voice into our
policy frameworks and such so that's my
presentation Thank You Donna okay so
we've been using this this word civil
society civil society organization can I
see a raise of hand who's comfortable
with the notion of civil society
organization could define it in four
words not me I'm just no no because I
must okay wonderful okay so that
introduces our first question what is a
civil society organization
everyone knows civil society could be a
movement like me too but what's a civil
society organization is it a non-profit
are all nonprofit civil society
organizations so I'm going to pitch that
question to my four panelists and see
what we come up with so I'll keep my
answer short I guess in in this case for
me civil society organizations or
community organizations this could be
homeless shelters they could also be
larger non-governmental organizations
such as wildlife conservation
organizations WWF WCS so in our work
when we talk about collaborating with
these civil society organizations it
would be these local community
organizations or these non-government
Road
yeah I would say in what my experience
with them as I mean you might think of
big NGOs and big national organizations
but really I think of small
mission-driven organizations that might
be for-profit social enterprises they
might be nonprofits but they're
basically collective individuals that
are in a community that are usually
building some kind of organizational
response to a problem on the ground that
they themselves have decided it's time
to solve or put resources into yeah so
in line with that I think it's just like
he said mission driven because there's a
lot of gaps in society stuff that the
government is not thinking about stuff
that people who are in the private
sector are not thinking about so I'd say
it's just that yeah pretty much the same
thing so I think the key word for me is
a public good or the idea because
private sectors have their own interest
in government has its own interest so
civil societies they fill that niche are
they are they promote the diverse
interest of the citizens out there in
society okay and does anyone want to
talk about there okay we're gonna get
just diving to the next question I'm
curious to know what you think how can a
I scientists collaborate with civil
society organizations to achieve
sustainable developmental goals and we
might be using the word SDGs DG a little
bit but amongst the sustainable
development goals of course there's
climate change there's poverty access to
education access to health access to
justice gender issues so in trying to
achieve positive goals for SDGs how can
any scientist collaborate with civil
society organizations and you can answer
how you feel comfortable with me Linda
maybe you want to give it a start
so I'll emphasize the point I made we
immersion in the domain that this work
cannot be done by sitting in the lab and
just doing work by ourselves I'll give
two concrete examples one is we're
working with wildlife conservation
agency in Malaysia and this is work that
Fang also brought up because she was a
student with me then and so she was
coming up with these routes patrol route
for patrollers to follow in the forests
in Malaysia and we would send the routes
and I said this is not working
so why is it not working the shortest
distance between two points is not a
straight line which to us was extremely
confusing how is that possible so how
does the geometry you know world change
in Malaysia that that's happening so we
flew down to Malaysia patrolled with the
patrollers in the forest then we
suddenly realized that yeah shortest
distance between two points when you're
patrolling is not a straight line you
actually have to follow a riverbed and
contour lines on basically follow Ridge
lines and so forth so that you don't
consume as much energy this kind of
insight cannot be drawn by just sitting
in the lab because they aren't you know
only when you get into the field and
understand what's going on that's when
some of these insights become available
a second example is work that was going
on with our Social Work colleagues and
so I was listening to this conversation
going on between a colleague of mine a
computer scientist and a social worker
and so the computer science professor
was saying well I don't understand what
is your objective and she was really
expecting a answer that said well here's
a sum over n terms something something
something and the Social Work social
worker saying what's there not to
understand it is to make all the kids
drug-free and but but the computer but
that's not the objective the objective
has to be something more concrete so
these kinds of things can only if you
really immerse yourself and understand
what's going on that's when so this so I
guess going back to your question about
partnerships the key to me is really
this immersion in the domain and getting
out of the lab and in the field
thank you don't go okay so as a foodie
foods the perspective as a non-technical
person so I feel uh I really believe
that this is a this is not a technology
that gets domained within the earth that
gets confined within the domain of a
scientific field
it's like fora for a non practitioner
like myself I'm dealing with AI on a
daily basis this is becoming part of
lives of people who are not necessarily
in the field of artificial intelligence
so I really think that there is an there
is a need for scientists to be more
public minded about the work that
they're doing and then be willing to be
willing to engage with people who may
not be as proof proficient in speaking
about this technology and I think that
that shift in this course is essential
for for that collaboration yeah I would
say I'm gonna wonder about how the
collaboration quote-unquote goes down
and I think that we have as AI
researchers and specialists a lot of
power and resources were bringing the
table there's governments and and large
foundations and companies making big
investments in this and community
organizations are the ones that really
actually understand how to achieve the
problem like how to make progress on
these problems on the ground and often
collaboration is kind of a people swoop
in and say give us some data or tell us
about the problem and then they go back
to the lab and I think that
collaboration is really starting at an
even playing field and actually going
into communities and building authentic
relationships and finding out who the
leaders of communities are and working
with them in ways that give them
decision-making power and that respect
their time I see a lot of people coming
into communities sometimes and even
within the community center I work in
and researchers and technologists want
to come in and do some kind of
collaborative research but they don't
want to actually invest or or put any
resources into the organizations and
these are often organizations that are
working with very very limited funding
people volunteering their time
people working two or three jobs in
order to do their passionate community
service work and these are also the
people who can unlock the really
authentic relationships and potentially
I know there's been other panels today
about fairness and bias um for instance
in like if if we want to get better at
framing problems and actually really
doing work that is gonna relate and
resonate with people on the ground I
think it actually starts with having
those authentic relationships and making
sure that the collaboration is a true
collaboration the people on both sides
in the community and in the researcher
corporate setting are being seen as
people who have equal amount of
knowledge and importance and it can't
just be a sort of bespoke hey we want to
work with you which really just means we
want you to give us data for free or
something like this so like Michael when
we asked how this can happen in terms of
collaboration I think about the
practicalities yeah because it's it's
quite possible for people in tech
especially to just be siloed to be
sitting in their labs behind their
computers playing around with cool tools
so how do we get them aware to the fact
that there's this whole world out here
and your skills might be useful so I
don't know maybe a creation of a
platform of some sort where people can
interact I've seen our website I'm the
name escapes me but it's it's a bit like
cago where you put up challenges except
they're specifically for good yeah and I
think something like that would help if
you can give a computer scientist or a
machine learning engineer a very easy
way to plug in to what you're doing that
might be helpful so creating platforms
or just availing your data talking about
your problem and then being able to
iterate in terms of framing the problem
to see are we actually looking at the
correct data are we approaching it from
the right direction so yeah I'd go back
to the technicalities of how that
collaboration can happen okay I'd like
to maybe push the question a little bit
further I was at the United Nations
Thursday and Friday and we were talking
about the role of public institutions in
supporting a positive impact to
technologies and and my case is really
more talking about AI and we had a long
discussion that I think it really goes
down to the whole onboarding process and
you know if there's if there's a
platform will citizens and civil society
organization reach out to those those
platforms how do you help them
understand what their the needs are what
the potential of AI could be for their
their needs and and even joining those
two is not always obviously I've worked
with some nonprofit organizations who
work really hard at identifying their
need but they forget to consult the
machine learners and machine learners
are like well you can't do anything with
that data or that question and machine
learning doesn't apply to that and on
the other end there's sometimes civil
side organizations like my websites not
working so I'm not going to look into
data analytics so do you in in that
perspective you have any experience or
ideas to share in that that process
because million dying I know that you
you worked with homeless community and
Los Angeles so in that process there
must have been something interesting and
Michael and Kathleen dongle as well yes
okay we're starting over there okay I
can start go ahead I don't have any
practical examples but I was sitting at
a session earlier this week and the lady
was presenting work on I think a I for
children some she's developing a course
to for children to start getting
acquainted with the AI and one of the
examples she gave on the importance of
this work is a little girl who was
talking to alexa and asked Alexa a
question and Alexa I think Alexa said I
don't know and she was like oh that's
alright I'll ask the other Alexa and it
it it shows the fact that she does not
quite understand how the technology
works for her she sees this as almost
like a human like you can communicate
with it it's asking a question it gives
you an answer so
I don't see how we can fix this the way
I see it it needs to come from a
pre-emptive position yeah a place where
possibly everyone in whatever cost
you're undertaking does a unit in AI so
that you just understand the
possibilities how it can help you in
your area whatever it is and that would
make for more applied better application
of AI and also collaboration I think
yeah I think that uh it's about trying
to build the readiness like I think that
people talk about like thinking about a
platform you would probably frame that
as an opportunity we're gonna create an
opportunity for organizations to express
their need to AI researchers or
companies or whatever and I think that
often whenever people are talking about
creating these opportunities they assume
that people on the other end are ready
to meet the opportunity exactly as it's
going to be delivered so like a really
good example of something I saw and
interacting with some community
organizations in Pittsburgh was they
were doing a bunch of housing
development and they said well we're
gonna leave 20 houses for instance are
gonna be affordable housing in this
really nice new development and they'd
but they didn't fit like plant the seeds
in the community of letting people know
that like these were gonna come
available and then suddenly they came
available and they said they'd contact
in a couple organizations including ours
and said okay can can you get people to
move into these houses and it's like
moving is a huge process
we're gonna need months to talk and find
the right families that actually ready
to make this transition and then in the
end they ended up selling 17 of the
units because they were sitting on their
rolls and they only ended up three ended
up going to communities but because they
didn't have any preparedness on the
ground so I would say something similar
if you want to do some kind of effort
and create an opportunity like kind of
similar to what Kathleen's saying I
would say like start it by going out and
actually creating maybe some community
modules on the possibility of machine
learning for good or AI for good and
actually helping community organizations
know what the potential is and then
maybe six months after that open up the
actual prize or the you know competition
now for people to enter their ideas and
actually have some people out there
thinking about it as opposed to open it
up and then being like why aren't small
organizations working on youth
non-violence applying because they
probably have never thought about AI and
they're not at all exposed to this
problem or what the framework of solving
problems through this lens is and so I
think starting with educating people and
being very intentional about that would
create a lot better results on the other
end thank you so in our experience for
the past 10 years or so we've been
working with these agencies and putting
out software that they eventually end up
using but every meeting or every first
meeting first set of meetings always
starts out with users sitting with their
arms folded like this and saying you
know we have decades of experience in
whatever tasks that they're doing we
have decades of experience for example
our first application was with airport
police in improving there are locations
like we have decades of experience in
you know doing our job what can your AI
system possibly provide that we don't
already know or we have decades of
experience you know patrolling with
these boats in the Port of New York
what can you professors sitting in USC
tell us that we don't already know so
that's always the first line of response
and it takes time to build up trust via
transparency of the program to under
start of explanations and so forth to
come to a point where finally they begin
to understand yes this is providing some
new insights that is complementing what
they already know it's not a threat but
it's a it's a decision aid that's
helping them out and it's you know
there's a beautiful incident where one
of our postdoctoral researchers were
working with Los Angeles Sheriff's
Department trying to improve collection
of you know trying to check for people
who travel without tickets on trains in
LA so the first meeting was exactly like
this you know we don't need you to the
last after exercise was conducted and we
showed that this software was really
useful to the officer going and hugging
the postdoc saying this is a really
great software and so there's this big
transformation but it can't happen
overnight there needs to be this process
of trust that often gets built up now
you can't do this at scale but for the
first application first innovative
application it seems like that's the
process that we want to go through and
once once the first domino falls then
you know throughout that organization or
so forth then you know then it's very
easy but the first one is always it
seems somewhat difficult so I I
understand that there's there social
dialogue is extremely important building
trust education is extremely important
I'm going to move on to the the next
question we got into a little bit of
semantics while we were discussing if I
say development of AI and implementation
of AI depending on Whitefield you're in
you might go into very very different
directions so I thought if I add social
implementation of AI is it a bit clearer
and we were still going in two very
different directions so I'm going to let
my panelists maybe I can start with
Dongwoo who's then more the policy of
politics and social science a
perspective of the question get the ball
started on what's the difference between
development of AI and implementation of
it okay so again as a non-technical
person the division is a little clearer
to me because development is what
engineers and scientists do and
deployment or implementation is well the
part of the technology that we actually
see on our day to day life so I'm
thinking about the actual use of AI for
deciding the the pearl length or the use
of AI for a home speakers and such or
job screening
so that's implementation that's
implementation to me so when technology
is visible in a sphere that's not entire
technical and and I think the fact that
we're talking about implementation and
developments in defense partially at
least it points to the the importance of
am thinking about AI governance because
it it just points to how pervasive this
technology is going to be and how
there's gonna be a need for government
to get in and at least provide some sort
of guideline on how we should be
engaging with with this technology
because it really touches on issues of
public good when we talk about the
development and then the deployment I
think in in very technical terms because
that's my background
I actually just see does me sitting on
my laptop deciding what features of the
data makes sense training a model and
then deploying it and then hey I'm done
but it's it's a very narrow view because
it doesn't take into account the fact
that's okay you've deployed it now this
thing exists and it's interacting with
the real world and it's making decisions
and it's affecting people so I do think
that the social aspects of it is
something that we needs to interrogate
more and then come up with frameworks
for deciding even should this be
deployed is it ready to be deployed if
have we thought about everything that
could go wrong in addition to all the
things that's we think it is going to do
right thank you I would actually maybe
even just add in order to create the
clarity in my mind I would add actually
another piece of semantics that then I
think clarifies more which is AI design
which I feel like there's kind of three
phases where you have design which is
deciding how the problems gonna be
framed how a person's gonna interact
with it who are the end-users gonna be
or is there gonna be a human in the loop
is it gonna be fully automated and maybe
even starting to think about the
transparency requirements is there is
there a lot of due process or liability
things like this and things that we
could bring in a lot of social and
outside expertise in that design and
then you get into development where it
is to me yeah very technical I'm just
thinking about like well which model am
I going to use
now hopefully I've gotten from my
designers good recommendations on data
sources and that's like in an ideal
world that you know making me aware of
biases making me aware of limitations of
my data and now I'm actually doing the
development process to build accuracy
and then in deployment we're back out as
do you don't wan was saying yeah don't
Lua saying that it was now you're
talking about the government or you're
talking about an agency that's now
actually got of like put this in a
bureaucratic process or put this in
their processes which now is going to
take some kind of final adaptation but I
think that where I get confused with
these semantics is I'm thinking about
well development has all these other
components and when you say
implementation do you mean like coding
implementation or do you mean social
implementations that do you think adding
social helps but for me if I add this
design layer it actually helps built
break it up a little bit more into like
design development deployment yeah cool
thank you million did you have a so I
mean I'm in agreement there's the phase
where the software gets developed in the
lab and there's the actual deployment in
the field and certainly we have to be
careful about the negative implications
you deploy something and it didn't work
out the way it was is there some sort of
a bias and so I also wanted to point out
sometimes you deploy things and there's
a positive outcome that you didn't
anticipate and that's sort of a good
thing where an AI system removed the
bias that human beings were bringing to
the table and so for example in the work
that we were doing with homeless youth
the software was recommending youth that
people were ignoring these were people
who within the homeless community were
isolated nodes people who were being
ignored as peer leaders to spread
influence that the AI system picked up
on and by giving that attention not only
did they spread messages effectively and
so forth but it turned out that changed
their life around that they got more
stable housing more stable jobs and so
it was sort of a unanticipated positive
outcome and it's also important to sort
of follow up on in the deployment phase
both the positive and the negative and
both both
and happen we are often focused on the
negative outcomes in deploying a but
sometimes really interesting positive
things happen that are unanticipated as
well oh my I think we're gonna run it
down because I yes I agree there are
risks and there's a lot of pot potential
positive potential and then the next
question normally would have been how
can we make sure that there's more of
that positive potential being deployed
but I'm going to I think I have like
about we have a quick drill question and
then we're gonna pass the floor to for
questions if you want to get ready if
you have some questions okay so there's
a limit there element a eyes on Francois
Gong he did a research and pointed out
that there's 22,000 AI researchers in
the world that's that's really not a lot
so I think he was quite an accounting
maybe only PhDs but still it there's
there's definitely a limited amount of
AI talent in the world so given that the
it's scarcity is there a social
responsibility for AI scientists to
share their expertise to achieve
sustainable development goals unto you
who wants to go first I think we need to
start with the scientists first and then
this kind of seems to me like asking
whether you for capitalism or socialism
I definitely do not think okay so they
do have a social responsibility but then
again you cannot tell them you have to
do this because we each have our own
free will I can choose to use my skill
for profit or not I think perhaps the
way forward is to suggest that companies
that have access to this talent or that
have this talent say something like hey
maybe one day in a month you concentrate
on a project that's for social good it's
it's common knowledge that Google does
this with their employees in terms of
them getting to spend a certain amount
of their time on pet projects and
they've gotten products out of that so
maybe it's just a matter of saying okay
you've got this skill the world is in
need of it it's in short supply so how
about you just dedicates part of your
time to something
that you care about thank you yeah I
mean I think I agree with Kathleen it's
I mean how do you force it but you know
I'm I guess bias in this way I made that
choice of like leaving a very profitable
sector to go and be in a community and
be engaged in building relationships and
bridges in and out of that community for
for good to happen and I can say like in
only a year of doing that I already see
how bringing you know my skills and
passion to people that already there's a
lot of lives changing right around me so
to me that's like way better than a
better salary and and it I think that
the impression would be like well does
that mean your careers dead and what did
you do why'd you get all these skills
and it's like no it's not actually
because this talent pulls so limited if
people are out in the community I
personally think companies will go out
to you and they'll figure out ways they
can work with you because I mean that's
what I'm seeing I still have people
pinging me about projects and about all
kinds of things it's not like they were
like oh you went into the community
therefore you're dead to me no it's like
you're still have a particular skillset
and we want to find people who are doing
that so I actually think there's a lot
of power that AI researchers have and
they can make that choice if they like
and it's probably good for other people
well I'm mostly in agreement with what's
being said it's certainly very important
for us as AI researchers to bring you
out to those who have not benefited from
it for example in the global South it's
also important for us to bring to
participate in interdisciplinary
partnerships in order to bring benefits
of AI because we ourselves can do the
job but we can't force it certainly and
so I'll leave it at that in the interest
of time so I don't disagree if I feel
like if we rely on the goodness of the
people then we often get into trouble so
we could have a really nice American
president but sometimes you could have
someone who is not as nice so we can't
really depend on the goodness of people
to things work out
and I think that's a policymaker
perspective so while it's great that
people like Mike is doing excellent work
in community we shouldn't rely on that
we should create policy framework in
which we produce more or AI
practitioners or a citizen form or AI
literate and also all may be policy that
that provides more funding more support
for people who are willing to go into
non-for-profit and you know I look at AI
politicians South Korea China and Japan
and I say that it's really comprehensive
and when I say that it's comprehensive
it's really really comprehensive so the
Chinese are testing out AI curricula at
the level of elementary school like it's
a pilot program but they're testing that
out they call it AI but I I'm thinking
that it's a coding program but a pointer
and South Koreans are also talking about
integrating AI education into high
school curriculum as well
universities are talking about creating
specialized high program where you you
become an expert in using AI in a
specific vector so you don't have to be
a PhD graduate but you'll be proficient
in working in a smart factory where AI
is being used so talent issue I think
with time it'll it'll get better but
which we could support that a little
better through policy because relying on
the goodness of people it can be really
really dangerous well I'd like to and
maybe open the floor to questions we
have yes thank you so much for the great
panel
I was wondering I'm very passionate
about the social science approach to
action research as an approach to
understanding the process by which our
great make systems are used in the socio
technical context in which they exist
and you kind of talked about this
already like we we need to think about
trust and but this action research field
aims to promote trustworthiness over
general generalization right but as AI
engineers we are trained to
score algorithms based on how well they
generalize and I was wondering how
what's your perspective on how could how
should we go about developing metrics to
think about even measuring something
like trustworthiness so that in the
future we can incorporate this sort of
comparison between structurally by
comparing algorithms thank you so very
quickly I think what you're pointing out
is an issue I see we face sometimes in
publishing certainly in conferences is
that we value generalization like you're
saying algorithms that are
general-purpose and so on so forth
whereas these are applications that we
are trying to put out there that have
impact and it there's a tension there in
being able to publish this work because
on one hand there is you know there's
the need to publish these
general-purpose results versus this so
for example a triple-a I this year we
let a track AI for social impact that
tried to get at this issue trying to
encourage research which values not only
the general purpose algorithm but clever
data collection clever pilot experiments
in order to see the value of the work
that's done model you know modeling
choices and so forth and so we have to
engage as a community in these sorts of
exercises in order to encourage people
to be able to publish in in prestigious
venues without necessarily emphasizing
just just the algorithmic improvement
but also the impact that it achieves in
the real world are there any other no I
don't think I see anyone okay so I yes
yeah
thank you for discussion it was really
interesting I want to note that how we
can increase
and interest in public in AI among
public that have no background in AI
because people does have background in
AI they usually search and increase date
knowledge but people without any
education in how we can actually engage
them how we can increase their knowledge
in the field of AI yeah I think that
this starts one strategy I mean I could
think of a number of strategies that are
all gonna actually have something to do
with going and creating community
programs that are actually about
creating educational opportunities they
might actually require some kind of even
prerequisite working with someone who
has a relationship in the community or
having some even prerequisite courses
and investing in actually having some
interest yes sir stats or math courses
and I see you know I can say from the
our Community Center it took a little
bit of time but you know even after six
months of just us kind of chatting about
the stuff with kids and slowly the
adults and the community getting to know
us people are suddenly like wait a
second I do you guys have you guys have
computer courses I know some of you guys
do computer stuff and it's like oh yeah
well we'll design them around what you
guys want and and now we actually have a
lot going forward on that but I think
that one of the places I see is an
opportunity to meet that challenge is
actually in the way that universities do
they're like broader impacts and
outreach on their grants grants require
broader impacts and outreach I'm not
super impressed with how these are right
now they could actually potentially put
some budget into having a community
liaison hiring someone in the community
that could help figure out where these
gaps are someone who actually builds the
four year five year relationship with
someone and then actually deploy classes
and things that are very targeted at
places where you have those
relationships and trust I definitely
think that that would work especially if
it was done over the course of like more
than six months or a year where you
first started with the trust building
and then put the classes then once you
have the relationships I think it could
work really well yeah
again I'm just gonna say the same thing
it's uh it's gonna be government again
um so for a non-technical person like me
or like in the policy world everyone is
trying to break into AI and blockchain
because the government says that they
are they're interested in pursuing it so
for example the government of canada
hosted a policy proposal competition
about a about six months ago and then
the requirement was doing something in
by making a proposal using AI or
blockchain so maybe it's a pose worthy
thing but they really gathered a lot of
attention within academia that's not
necessarily aligned with a like the
field of artificial intelligence machine
learning computing science and if and
when I look at East Asian policies they
are comprehensive and they provide a
very concrete vision that the government
will be behind in supporting this
technology so the companies and citizens
they become aware and that they they
want to get into it somehow so maybe
that same strategy is not gonna work
exactly the same here in Canada or the
United States but then the leadership
are saying that this is going to be you
know the fourth Industrial Revolution
something that says impactful as the
first thing Industrial Revolution and
articulating a vision in which
technology is being used it's gonna be
used I think that's gonna be helpful you
know raising awareness because it has
worked in in East Asia if you read a
South Korean newspaper there is not a
single day where artificial intelligence
is not difficult in one way or the other
thank you well I I would like to to
conclude I think based on their question
Priya
there's really many different ways and
channels and therefore specialties
expertise disciplines and people there's
going to many different ways there's
digital literacy programs there's
education programs there's many
different ways of onboarding the
population we can go through the arts
like Michael and other artists and like
Luba Elliot I think she's just like in
one of the
rooms over here there's many different
ways of engaging citizens and it goes
pure outrage we're just calling them
talking to them give them insight and
I'll have to just plug in my conference
very quickly which called AI and a
social mission one quarter of the
participants are civil society
organizations the other 25 30 percent
are AI scientist then we have social
innovators in the room so really you
know getting together learning how to
work in multidisciplinary multi sectoral
teams is extremely important not be an
an art is a beautiful way because it's
not intimidating anybody will feel
engaged by public art and we can start
start the conversation that way so I
would like to thank from the bottom of
my heart
million Tembe for being here today
Mike's kirpan Kathleen semi-new and
Dongwoo Kim I really appreciate thank
you for being here
you